[Music]
Walter pepper and chili Lavinia Billy
Idol mahooty Stevie Wonder opus sloly
top hat right now I think I have about
36 turtles I'm Laurie Kramer
I'm the turtle lady of Manhattan I'm the
only wildlife rehabilitator in the city
that works just specifically with
Turtles I Rehab turtles in an apartment
in New York City bringing Turtles into
the country illegally has become big
business
I get Turtles from the Department of
Environmental Conservation US Fish and
Wildlife the urban park rangers even by
policemen last summer I had 680 baby
turtles that were brought here from the
Department of Environmental Conservation
it's overwhelming to have a large amount
of turtles in a New York City apartment
I promised my husband a bathroom and a
bedroom without turtles the back
bathroom is where we take ours if I
lived outside the city and I had a yard
I probably would be rehabilitating all
kinds of wild animals but here in
Manhattan turtles are perfect when I was
a child there was no place for women in
vet school but somehow things come full
circle I'm a turtle nurse that's
basically it I think that I did good
turtle points in heaven
[Music]
there are countless Chinatown's all over
the world in New York boasts one of the
most famous full of cheap produce fish
markets and of course a plethora of
Chinese food but if you hop on the one
train take it to the Upper West Side
you'll find a Chinese restaurant like no
other
perhaps the menu is something else to
ellipta chicharonnes
ropa vieja first on a cross III hole
this is la caridad 78 New York's last
Cuban Chinese restaurant comida China
Grill oh yeah three oh yeah how did this
unlikely culinary duo come to be it's a
great question
enter Sam Lee so my wife remember father
came over here or he started I like his
own restaurant would he like upin spices
and also the Chinese put mixed together
hundreds of thousands of Chinese came to
Cuba in the 19th and early 20th century
establishing a strong presence on the
island but when Castro came to power
most Chinese immigrants like Sam's
father left many of them coming to the
US and thus Cuban Chinese food was born
I would say luckily that restaurant is
not restaurant is a kitchen for Upper
West siders we have oxtail robbery ah
which is like a shredded beef at the
same time we search Irish food either
cooked for my you know mainly from China
and they learn the train when they got
here and they become very good so are
there any Cuban born workers left I
still have a one kilburn worker working
for me
again I see enemy Kamino me and again my
name is Antonia Wong I work in the
career I'm a stallion 1986 I'm born in
Havana Cuba in 1951 analyst key one work
invisible while Cuban Chinese culture is
fading la caridad is a snapshot of a
strange moment in time where two vastly
different cultures merged together the
Cuban Chinese people getting older and
they don't have any younger people to
take over I myself felt like I all my
father who started this restaurant so I
want to try to make sure that I carry on
the tradition for him pop quiz hotshot
you're in Harlem and you're at this
building you go through the door enter
the security code take the elevator to
the third floor knock on this door where
Rudy greets you hi and welcome make your
way into a packed apartment and try to
find a seat what do you get you get a
live jazz performance like no other
[Music]
every Sunday Marjorie Elliot and her son
Rudel drear's open the doors to their
apartment for people to come and listen
to jazz music we decided to use our
apartment because we can do what we want
here it's just a matter of this is home
so everybody who walks through that door
we treat his family and it's a pretty
big family the concerts are so popular
that if you're not on time finding a
seat can be a little tricky we fill up
the living room the kitchen hallway
people will stand out making videos it's
pretty much like that every Sunday now
you know it's like it's jam-packed
the jazz concerts began in 1993 after
rudel's brother Phil passed away well my
brother passed away on a Sunday and
whelming had the great idea to honor him
with concerts on Sundays you know and
you play music you just get all your
angst out and it's just a healing
feeling so I think our thing was you
know what better way to honor him and
with the concert and we've been blessed
to never Evans to Sunday with their
commitment and consistency to play every
Sunday the concerts are now considered
legendary in Harlem attracting audiences
from all over the world
hey Rudel do you mind if we ask some of
the audience members where they came
from
of course I'm from Germany France
Australia Kuran yeah that's pretty cool
I think once we started it just took on
a life force of its own sometimes people
come and they just they don't know what
they're gonna expect you know it's like
Ringo Dell and get free jazz and then
once they get here
they have that experience it's kind of
something they won't forget
[Music]
[Applause]
for some people this is their church
people come here and I feel renewed and
we feel renewed and you never know who
you're gonna touch out there so you're
putting out good energy it's gonna work
a bird in New York City doesn't have it
easy
whether it's flying into a building a
car a bicycle dogs pollution lead poison
this is not nature's natural course we
have interfered with it my name is Rita
McMahon and I'm the co-founder and
director of the wild bird fund New York
City's one and only wildlife
rehabilitation center we take in birds
that anyone has found and we do our best
to make it whole so that it can go back
to the wild the atmosphere at the wild
bird fund is something of a three-ring
circus
there's the ISO room waterfowl room
reception area and downstairs is a whole
other thing there are a couple of
hundred Birds down there they may be
flying around in the air as people are
scurrying around cleaning the cages
giving them meds and feeding them we
deal with 135 different species this
past week we had a Canada Goose 7
kestrels a rowdy bunch of juvenile
herring gulls this year 2016 we will
treat well over 4,000 Birds
by being in New York City where the
animal is found we are able to save many
more animals they would die before they
could get help in another state or
another County people can come to you
via a subway or bus and they can get the
animal to you faster it's exciting you
never really know who's gonna walk
through that door or what they're
holding in that box I was at my store
and I saw the pigeon I saw that he was
like bleeding on the floor like pretty
bad I didn't even know that they took in
pigeons any animal that is picked up is
in really bad shape 50% will die or are
euthanized if we can reduce the
suffering that's a good thing too but
50% go free when the birds better you
try to return it to where it came if
it's an adult bird it might have family
friends it knows where to live the
migratory birds they're just passing
through you're really just trying to put
them in a safe place so that they can
continue their journey
[Music]
[Applause]
people tell me that New York can be the
best place in the world and most social
place in the world I can also be the
loneliest place in the world as well the
goal of this supper club is to bring
people together
[Music]
my name is Vincent Wu and I am known for
running a supper club called mr. Jones
supper club yeah I'm gonna gather
scallops in the basement of my apartment
chives and small basket of the shallots
it started when I got here about three
years ago I didn't know anyone and I
miss getting together around the kitchen
with friends eating and so I started
with acquaintances and then one thing
led to another and it sort of blew up I
only do it two times a month but the
demand is over two three years now and
that's that's rounding down guests do
not have to pay to come you pay whatever
you feel like at the end of the night
based on how much they enjoy the
experience and how much they they can
afford
I'm not formally trained in cooking
what's that YouTube it's probably my
teacher every month and mr. Jones has no
menus ever the same last Saturday we
started off with some burrata and then
it was accompanied by two nut citta and
topped with fried lotus root chips then
we had scallop crudo it also held on
Asian flavors as well then we had the
mushroom on mushroom on mushroom which
is like big chunky maitake mushroom
baked in the oven I love doing this I
definitely have made friends from it
people have definitely made friends with
with each other from it as well my first
time like you know finding long-lost
people together I think it's a good way
just to stop and get people to be
present sometimes with people without
phones and just just talk and get to
know someone
you